yan monplaisir bonjour bonjour bonjour à
vous et aux auditeurs alors y'a mon
plaisir candidats à nouveau on est tenté
de dire à l'élection aux élections
municipales à saint joseph
oui parce que vous vous êtes déjà
présenté plusieurs fois auparavant et
j'ai été conseiller général de saint
joseph absolument vous avez déjà eu
l'occasion d'être élu dans le canton 2
de saint joseph vous faites bien de le
rappeler mais yan monplaisir
vous êtes actuellement premier vice
président de l'assemblée de martinique
ça veut dire que si vous êtes élue
l'année prochaine maire de saint-joseph
bassin mandat auquel il vous faudra
renoncer pour non cumul de ce raid
exécutif je devrais démissionner de ma
responsabilité de premier vice président
mais je resterai membre de l'assemblée
j'ai fait un choix j'ai fait un choix
après l'avoir bien mesuré bien pesé
c'est pour ça que j'étais pressée par la
population qui me disait il faut y aller
on compte sur vous et je leur disais je
réfléchisse parce que c'est un choix qui
est évidemment un choix important pour
moi dans ma démarche est dans mon
engagement politique alors mais qu'elles
sont calés le principal ou deux
principaux motifs pourquoi avoir voulu
retenter cette expérience reste à
relever à nouveau ce défi très
simplement parce que c'est une commune à
laquelle je suis attaché mes enfants ils
sont nés j j'ai vécu je suis toujours en
relation avec cette population
et puis aussi parce que les
circonstances m'ont conduit à me dire
que j avais une attente que la situation
de la commune impliquait qu'il y ait
quelqu'un à la fois d'expérimenter
quelqu'un qui est aussi les réseaux qui
puisse favoriser le redressement de
cette commune et assurer son
développement
j'ai répondu à une à un appel c'est vrai
que un peu tous les candidats dit cela
mais j'ai vraiment pris du temps j'ai
vraiment été au devant des gens parce
qu'il y avait des gens qui venaient me
voir qui m'appelait qui me disaient mais
on compte sur vous pourquoi vous ne vous
prononcez pas j'ai pris le temps de la
réflexion
alors il ya un contexte particulier
incontestablement à saint joseph
on sait que le maire sortant a été
condamné en appel
une mesure de non éligibilité en fait il
il restait en mairie il est resté maire
du seul fait qu'il a fait un pourvoi en
cassation ce qui suspend l'application
de la condamnation qu'il a subi mais ce
qui pourrait peut-être lui permettre si
la cour de cassation ne se prononçait
pas avant mars 2020 ils permettent
finalement de se présenter et de
solliciter les suffrages des josefin
qu'est ce que ça vous fait ce contexte
particulier je suis candidat parce que
j'ai un projet une vision pour saint
joseph
il faut d'abord redresser les finances
de cette ville les la situation
financière de l'avs delà de la commune
de saint-joseph est catastrophique et je
me donne à peu près deux ans pour le
faire ce qui ne veut pas dire que
pendant ces deux années je ne ferai rien
il y a d'abord il faut construire des
projets aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
projets à imaginer parce qu'il n'ya pas
grand chose d'après ce que je sais dans
les tiroirs
par exemple l'hôpital va déménager dans
quelques mois il n'y a pas de projet
qu'est ce qu'on fait à la place de
l'hôpital ça va faire un vide nouveau
dans le centre ville moi ce que je veux
c'est redynamiser le bourg de saint
joseph et pour cela il faut que lier de
l'attractivité dans le beau il faut
d'abord qu'on reconstruise l'hôtel de
ville ça fait 25 ans que l'hôtel de
ville a été déménagé dans une école je
reconstruirai l'hôtel de ville je ferai
en sorte qu'il y ait de l'animation
culturelle il ya un cinéma qui est la
propriété de la commune on reconstruira
ce cinéma avec des fonds de l'adac
j'ai également l'intention de renforcer
la dynamique dans les quartiers il ya
des quartiers qui ont besoin de vie par
exemple gdg des idées très précises sur
ce qu'il faut faire dans des quartiers
qu'ils ont besoin d'équipements de
proximité inciter à la réouverture de
boutiques ce qu'on appelle les boutiques
chez nous dans les petits quartiers
comme je pense par exemple au monde d
olive vous pensez qu'on aime une mouette
besoin d'une boîte de lait amandes des
olives vous êtes une personne âgée il
n'y a pas deux ou pas assez de moyens de
transport vous êtes coincés là oh non il
faut une petite boutique c'est le lieu
des changes
mais pour ça il faut que ce soit viable
économiquement
et pour cela il faut mettre des
dispositifs d'attractivité dans ce
domaine donc obligé j'ai une verrue
attitude de projets là donc la situation
personnelle particulière du maire
sortant ne vous préoccupent pas
tellement le passé c'est le passé
je sais que des erreurs ont été commises
tout le monde commet des erreurs des
erreurs ont été commises la situation
est ce qu'elle est je suis un
pragmatique je connais la situation je
connais les difficultés je veux
rencontrer le personnel
ce sera aussi une de mes priorités
redresser les finances rencontré
personnel les mettre dans une dynamique
positive leur expliquer que que nous
devons tous co construire cette commune
et puis donner de l'allant à saint
joseph
dernière question il yal montplaisir le
maire de saint joseph a été aussi ces
dernières années le président de la
cacem est-ce que vous pensez que ça a
bénéficié à la ville de saint joseph qui
parfois apparaît comme un petit peu le
parent pauvre un petit peu la dernière
roue du carrosse peut être de cette
alliance au sein de la communauté
d'agglomération prise entre la menthe h
el cheikh et fort de france 3 trois
grosses villes
je pense que le fait d'avoir un maire en
30 secondes
malheureusement le fait d'avoir un maire
d'expérience le fait d'avoir un maire
qui est un poids politique est sera un
avantage pour la commune de saint-joseph
en tout cas je mettrai à la fois comme
je les dis mon savoir mais mon
expérience mes disponibilités mon poids
politique et aimer réseau politique au
service de saint joseph et c'est pour ça
qu'ils y compris au sein de la cac seb y
compris au sénat kacem et au sein de la
collectivité territoriale au niveau de
l'état en fait si vous voulez c'est
joseph a besoin d'une impulsion et je
crois que au moment où on parle j'ai à
la fois l'énergie et l'expérience pour
vous donner cette impulsion à cette
commune merci il ya non plaisir ce soit
aux cadis spécial municipal été réalisée
par patrice à la guise à lachy bonne
journée à vous